[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sail
israels heute gibt es mal wieder seit
langem eine motiv torte ich habe nämlich
eine anfrage bekommen von warner bros ob
ich denn nicht zum neuen film
fantastische tier wesen teil 3 einem
motiv torte zaubern möchte und ich würde
sagen ich zeige euch jetzt erst mal kurz
den trailer denn ich habe auch eine
nachricht von jacob bekommen film ab
wir brauchen erinnerungen
und sie sind wir blind
ohne sie überlassen wir dem zufall der
schicksal unserer welt
[Musik]
es tut mir leid sie zerstören alles aber
es gibt beunruhigende neuigkeiten worum
geht es dabei um grindelwald
unsere stunde rückt näher meine brüder
und schwestern unser krieg die
muschelbänke und
[Musik]
die welt wie wir sie kennen löst durch
auf
wenn wir ihnen wie sie den ball
dann müssen sie mir vertrauen ist der
kongo als er brauchen sich sagt ich
brauche sie nicht mehr los
aber sie wissen dass ich eine hexe wenn
dumbledore hat mich gebeten die etwas zu
geben
[Musik]
diese truppe wird den gefährlichsten
zauberer seit langem zur strecke bringen
wer würde da nicht auf uns setzen
darf alles wissen nicht einmal durch
was du tust ist wahnsinn
ob mit oder ohne dich ich brenne ihre
welten die da
gefährliche zeiten
begünstigen gefährliche mensch
wenn wir bis zur teezeit noch alle am
leben sind dürfen wir unser unterfangen
als erfolg betrachten mester kowalski
ist mir ein vergnügen
[Musik]
hast du wirklich vorteil des gleichen
den rücken zuzukehren
[Musik]
du hast davon gesprochen die welt um zu
gestalten selbst wenn die fehler begehen
[Musik]
tokio
so können wir doch versuchen sie ihre
gut zu machen
[Musik]
wir werden etwas hier verbrauchen
selbst du kannst mich nicht aufhalten
[Musik]
die dinge sind nicht so wie sie scheinen
haben sie freude an ihrem zauberstab
minister kowalski
darf ich ihn behalten
[Musik]
wir brauchen sind ich sagte ich bin raus
und ich genoss
aber sie wissen dass ich ein headset
zum downloaden
liebe wie sie können löst sich auf 130
hast auseinander
wir werden hilfe brauchen wenn wir ihn
besiegen wollen
[Musik]
darf ich ihn behalten
also ihr habt jacob kowalski gehört wir
backen jetzt was schönes zusammen ich
habe mir überlegt einen kuchen zu backen
der aussieht wie der koffer von news
kämen dem maggi zoologen und darauf
setzt sich eine süße kleine figur
nämlich den löffler ich glaube das wird
richtig schön und ich hoffe das gefällt
euch auch gut also ich schaue jetzt den
koffer an und versucht den
originalgetreuen auch trocken
sehr schön da bin ich jetzt fertig und
kann jetzt mit dem backen beginnen ich
werde zuerst einmal einen großen
rührkuchen zu bereiten daraus wird der
koffer zubereitet und um löffler kümmere
ich mich später
für den rücken verwende ich 250 gramm
weiche butter 60 gramm honig 200 gramm
zucker eine prise salz etwas vanille
extrakt 4 1 die haben bereits
raumtemperatur 400 gramm mehl oder
verwendet normales mail plus backpulver
400 milliliter milch die darf auch gern
warm sein 200 gramm gehackte und
geröstete haselnüsse und hier habe ich
noch 150 gramm cookie dough fajads den
ofen bereits vorgeheizt und ich mag den
kuchen gleich hier im bug rahmen den
ziehe ich komplett auf also bis auf
backblech größe und wenn ich ihn darin
backe statt auf einem herkömmlichen
backblech sorge ich dafür dass praktisch
da kuchen eine schöne ebene fläche
bekommt das heißt er hat keine beule in
der mitte er geht nicht in der mitte auf
und außen nicht sondern er wird schön
gerade schön flach und vor allem
gleichmäßig gebacken und die backzeit
ist auch viel schneller das erste was er
jetzt macht indem die weiche butter und
verrührt sie mit dem honig zucker und
salz und vanille extrakt zu einer
cremigen masse
anschließend kommen die eier einzeln
dazu und da wird jedes eine halbe minute
ungefähr mit eingerührt zum schluss
könnte jetzt noch backpulver und mehr
vermischen oder ihr verwendet wie gesagt
das bak mail gibt es back mit dazu die
milch und auch die gehackten und
gerösteten haselnüssen die zutaten dann
nur noch ganz kurz einrühren und die
cookie dough fudge es nur noch kurz
unterheben
[Musik]
man kommt jetzt der teig direkt hier
rein und wird im ofen gebacken vorher
natürlich noch schön verteilen und die
cookie dough features die die schmerzen
so ein bisschen im backofen und sorgen
dafür dass der teig einfach so eine
schöne feucht die konsistenz bekommt und
natürlich geschmacks geber die sind sehr
sehr lecker ich muss sagen ich nachsteht
so ganz gerne und in muffins in suzuka
und
toppings man kann aber ohne karamell
krems schmelzen mit dieser tiefen winkel
palette einfach verteilen und direkt
packen
[Musik]
der kindersitz gebacken und ich habe ihn
auch schon abkühlen lassen ich hätte in
der zwischenzeit auch schon die reis
crispy master machen nun können aber ich
habe es nicht gemacht ich habe jetzt auf
den kuchen erwartet und habe jetzt hier
die zutaten für meine buttercreme
füllung ich möchte dass der kuchen so
ein bisschen schmeckt wie ein bahnhof
bei also ein kuchen mit bananen mit
karamell mit leckeren zutaten und habe
jetzt hier eine creme für euch die zwar
ein bisschen fertig ist aber so sind
horten nun mal so ist es halt ich
brauche dafür für die karamell
buttercreme brauche ich 300 gramm weiche
butter 400 gramm karamell
milchmädchen creme und weiß es einfach
so eine kondensmilch die karamellisiert
ist 200 gramm frischkäse etwas salz und
zimt und den frischkäse nämlich jetzt
einfach noch so das ist ein bisschen ein
bisschen aufgelockert wird ansonsten
könnt ihr wirklich wenn ihr nun eine
reine buttercreme machen wollt einfach
diese butter und diese karamell
kondensmilch nehmen und etwas salz und
ich geb klein auch zimt dazu für den
geschmack jetzt gebe ich erst mal die
butter in
die rührschüssel mit rasanz und rühre
sie erst mal
weiß cremig
[Musik]
währenddessen scheele und schneide ich
die bananen vermengen sie dann mit dem
zitronensaft damit sie nicht braun
werden
[Musik]
zur weiß cremigen butter rühre ich jetzt
noch die karamell creme ein und fügen
auf den cent hinzu
die sie zu lecker aus ich musste jetzt
echt probieren
zurück
aber ich gebe noch besonder karamell
dazu denn bei mir kommt ja noch frisch
käsereien
es wird mir das zu wenig karamell ich
[Musik]
und zum schluss rühre ich noch den
frischkäse 1
[Musik]
fertig ist die leckere creme
ich habe in der zwischenzeit auch schon
mal die bananen fein geschnitten also in
scheiben und noch mit zitronensaft
beträufelt damit sie nicht braun werden
und außerdem kriegt man dann so ein
bisschen ist eure noch mit rein was echt
ganz gut passt weil die gräber doch
recht wo trick ist
also nehme ich jetzt hier den kuchen
blech weg
nehmen torten retter darunter
und dann kurz entfernen
und dann werde ich jetzt einfach die
platte halbieren ja
genau weil da sind nämlich die ganzen
cookie dough falsches dann sind wir
nämlich im innern
jetzt streiche ich hier die creme
einfach drauf
[Musik]
die streicht es noch ein bisschen creme
drauf damit die bananen so ein bisschen
eingehüllt sind
[Musik]
so seht die torte jetzt erst mal aus
muss an die riecht echt schon wahnsinnig
gut ich werde jetzt einen packen mit
einem back haben einfach noch mal
außenrum stellen aber da werde ich
wahrscheinlich den kleinen nehmen müssen
und dann kommt die torte abgedeckt
erstmal in den kühlschrank und ich werde
dann ja so nacht eigentlich würden schon
zwei drei stunden kühl zeit reichen ich
werde allerdings bis morgen hatten und
dass die torte einfach im kühlschrank
und wird auch morgen dann erst die figur
machen
neuer tag neues glück jetzt wird die
torte
fertiggestellt hoffe ich zumindest ich
hoffe ich schaffe es heute mal schauen
ich werde jetzt erstmal eine schokoladen
genau stellen das ist eine verbindung
aus sahne und schokolade ich habe mich
jetzt hier für die vollmilch cora tore
entschieden und nehme dafür 200 gramm
schlagsahne 500 gramm vollmilch
kuvertüre und jetzt wird einfach die
sahne aufgekocht dann nehmt ihr den topf
vom herd herunter rührt die schokolade
ein bis sie komplett geschmolzen ist und
dann dürfte die ghanas gerne einfach
umfallen abdecken und bei raumtemperatur
stehen lassen damit sie eben abkühlen
kann
das ist hergestellt
kann jetzt hier ab kühl und dann geht es
jetzt eigentlich schon direkt weiter mit
der figur ich möchte den lift formen und
entweder mache das jetzt aus kuchenteig
jetzt mal ein bisschen schwierig weil
kuchen einfach sehr weich ist und dann
ein bisschen zerbrechen kann beim formen
und ich brauchte einfach ein bisschen
was festes aber trotzdem was leckeres
und deswegen gibt es jetzt
reiß christi masse und zwar braucht ihr
dafür diese chance ist praktisch
cerealien die gibt es in schoko und ich
meine auch in heller version aber
schokolade ist immer ganz gut und dann
verwendet ihr noch marshmallows dazu und
etwas butter und könnte damit eben arise
kristinas formen die wirklich dann auch
schön festes schön standfest aber eben
auch lecker und das bedeutet ich nehme
jetzt einfach die marshmallows und
schmerzt die in der mikrowelle oder in
einer pfanne aber da empfehle ich
wirklich eine mikrowelle weil es echt
viel einfacher geht als in der
mikrowelle etwa drei bis vier minuten
schmelzen und anschließend wird das
ganze mit dem schoko cookies verknetet
die butter kommt noch mit dazu und dann
wird daraus die figur geformt
[Musik]
genau so muss es aussehen das war der
ofen
da kommt jetzt die butter rhein und die
masse sieht jetzt nicht heiß aus aber
die ist wirklich heiß also seid da bitte
bitte vorsichtig
und dann gehe ich jetzt hier eiskristall
sie kurz ein und dann wird geknetet und
beim kneten hättet ihr am besten vorher
eure hände sonst geht alles immer dann
hätten viel spaß
[Musik]
und jetzt schön verkneten
bis sich alles verbunden hat und sobald
so langsam abkühlt kann man es nämlich
schön formen
gut dann wird jetzt der flak formt der
hat ja
eine schnauze den kopf okay da sieht
schon ein bisschen aus wie so ein
kleiner maulwurf ich muss da immer mal
auf meinen laptop schauen und versuche
jetzt einfach den kopf erstmal zu formen
und
sturm diesen buckel teil und dann
kriegen wir das schon irgendwie hin und
am besten form tier die masse fest indem
er sie immer wieder zerdrückt und die
kann man später auch zu schneiden das
ganz praktisch
ich weiß nicht ob ich ihn läge soll oder
ob ich ihn hinstelle ist und ich weiß es
nicht aber ich glaube es war süß wenn er
so macht so und so eine goldmünze in der
hand hat
[Musik]
das war uns trägt aber das reicht das
noch
die last aushalten
dann kümmere mich um den koffer
ich weiß ich bin verrückt aber
das war ja ursprünglich meinen koffer
und der reicht auch für als wenn ihr
zuhause die torte nach macht dann reicht
die größe auf jeden fall ich möchte aber
jetzt auch in der größeren orte macht
nicht mal meine hilfe zählt auch bisserl
größer geraten ich dachte eigentlich
tatsächlich dran ich nehme die hälfte
der rest christina aber ich will jetzt
auch nicht schon eine große gigantische
torte machen deswegen habe ich nochmal
und blechkuchen gebacken
jetzt wäre es natürlich einfacher
gewesen ich jetzt gleich zwei
blechkuchen gebacken gefüllt und
aufeinander gesetzt aber ich habe es mir
jetzt bisschen schwerer gemacht das
macht jetzt nichts ich mache jetzt hier
praktisch auch noch mal die hälfte
stückl dass man dran und dann habe ich
eine große torte
warum einfach wenn es auch kompliziert
geht frau ist
deswegen die butter noch ein bisserl
buttercreme hier das team freut sich das
ganze team auf die torte da kann ich
nicht sagen ich habe nur einen halben
blech ein halbes blech balompie
es gibt bahnhof für alle
ja jeder freut sich marcel freut sich
ich habe nämlich noch mal kann das
gemacht was ich
habe von ihm kommt jetzt ein
[Musik]
das ist jetzt mal ein koffer
da ist jetzt auch glaube ich echt schwer
ja ich drücke ihr noch
und dann kommt der jetzt in den
kühlschrank und so weiter fest ist kann
ich ihnen mit garage streichen denn ich
werde später nicht von dann schicht
drüber packen und bei fondant ist immer
wichtig dass die äußere schicht von dann
tauglich ist damit einfach der fondant
nicht auf weicht das bedeutet immer eine
schicht ohne zu viel wasser und garages
perfekt geeignet die amerikanische
buttercreme italienische buttercreme des
wismarer cream ist auch geeignet oder
eben auch diese karamell creme ohne
frischkäse und ich finde jetzt eine ganz
ganz gut weil die einfach schnell
aushärtet ich kann wunderbar damit
arbeiten und es erspart mir einfach ganz
ganz viel arbeit also kommt die torte
jetzt in den kühlschrank ich geh
vorhabens hände waschen und dann gucke
ich mir ob der ne flasche so weit ist
so sieht man jetzt aus jetzt bekommt er
ein fan aus schwarze marzipan und die
marzipan masse werde ich jetzt mit cmc
pulver verkneten das ist zellulose
pulver kann man mit luzern das ist ein
pulver was man eigentlich auch nimmt um
die dritten zähne anzukleben also
sozusagen alles lebensmittelecht ihr
könnt gerne ohne machen allerdings muss
ich sagen dadurch wird die figur einfach
auch schon fest und es passiert dann
eben auch nichts wert also verknetet
jetzt ein bisschen cmc prüfer mit
marzipan und schneit dann die figur aber
erst mal noch ein bisschen zu bevor ich
sie mit marzipan überziehen
okay zum kneten dazu hoch die theke
vergleich für diego ist es perfekt
einfach schön in form schneiden
das gute es bei dem man kann halt durch
das fell später dann doch wieder alles
irgendwie retten
die befestige und später den kopf hier
mit einem schaschlikspieß tja jetzt wird
aber erst einmal ausgerollt und
überzogen und ich glaube die arme
richtung auch aus prinzip und
gerne dürfte die marzipan masse auf
etwas becker stärker ausrollen und nicht
zu dünn
ich brauche auch gleich machen bis ich
und ich sehe ich jetzt schaffen das
reicht nicht aus
becker stärke ist ganz cool weil man sie
einfach mit pinsel wegwischen kann
deswegen eignet die sich perfekt zum
ausrollen und es besser als guter zucker
oder normaler stärke okay nicht zu dünn
ausrollen dann nehmt ihr euren löffler
körper
besprühte ihn gerne mit etwas sagt renz
break einfach zum kleben
und dann würde ich sagen
kommt es ja immer drüber
ich hoffe das klappt so wie ich mir das
vorstelle
du siehst dann mit der schere das fell
einschneiden sie einfach schön
faltenfrei darüber legen
und damit er so ein bisschen
dreidimensionaler wird
schneide ich das hier unten weg
bei dieser figur mache ich glaube ich
jetzt zum ersten mal so dass ich keine
ghana schicht darunter packen aber ich
will es nicht komplizierter machen als
es schon ist das heißt hier ist der
fertige körper und jetzt nämlich eine
nagelschere sauber sollte sie natürlich
sein und kann jetzt hier mit der
nagelschere das fell einschneiden am
besten fängt hier oben an und arbeitet
euch nach und danach kümmere ich mich um
kopf und die arme und beine und die
menschen habe
diesen haarschnitt den lernt man in der
friseur ausbildung im zweiten lehrjahr
haarschnitt für hitler
ich stell dir kurzzeitig pause und dann
geht es mit dem kopf weiter
ich glaube ich kann schon mal den
schnabel machen
und dafür vertrete ich etwas von danz
mit cnc pulver
damit der schnabel auch schon fest wird
das war jetzt so richtig meine hände
das war jetzt echt hart
jetzt kann ich den schnabel aus der
modelliermasse formen nehmen durch da
ruhig immer ein bild zur vorlage und
formt sie dann entsprechend
die form habe ich jetzt ungefähr
dann nehme ich mir modelle werkzeug
dann ein nasenloch
und noch ein nasenloch
die falten da oben die form ich gleich
noch das lege ich mal kurz zur seite das
wird jetzt so ein bisschen das
gegenstück das untere
damit praktisch das hier nicht so flach
ist
kommt es dann von unten noch dran
dann wird jetzt der kopf ummantelt sind
dabei seine magischen tier wesen sieht
da noch harmlos aus aber muttermalen
babykorb
dass sie total aus hier vorne den rand
da wo praktisch der schnabel drankommt
den könnte mit den fingerspitzen so ein
bisschen zusammen klemmen und auch hier
unten damit da später das fell über
steht beim anschneiden
so heiße luft fritteuse lkw autos
schön dass wir ein studio nahe der
straße haben den schnabel werde ich
jetzt
schon mal befestigen mit zahnstochern
ansonsten wird es nach vorne nicht
halten und
etwas essbarem kleber
damit praktisch die zwei schichten
zusammen wachsen
und dann mit sauberen händen hier den
schnabel fest drücken
und gern noch so ein bisschen in die
breite ziehen dann müssen da dringend
auch noch die augen dran es können ja so
ein bisschen mit ball tue einfach öffnen
und sozusagen die fläche dafür schaffen
[Musik]
sehr gut
jetzt sehe ich hier noch ein paar falten
hinein
und drückende öffnung für das auge rein
da kommen dann die schwarzen augen rein
[Musik]
und dann auch hier das fell einschneiden
und beim einschneiden des felles achtet
jetzt darauf dass er praktisch von vorne
nach hinten schneidet
[Musik]
so einmal kopf im nacken bitte
nacken schnitt nacken haarschnitt
[Musik]
ich glaube den flop sieht gut aus klasse
jetzt erstmal trocknen und muss meine
hand
ein bisschen schonen
und dann geht es gleich in die beine und
die arme
jetzt geht es mit dem modellieren weiter
ok
aus
heller modelliermasse form ich jetzt die
hände
und die hände haben leider nur vier
finger ich drück dir so ein bisschen
flach
dann haben die so kallen
ok ich drücke so ein bisschen flach
schneide vier finger zu und form sichern
und ganz am ende also jetzt sieht es
noch so ein bisschen sieht schon gut aus
aber es ist noch so ein bisschen
anfänger mäßig aus aber ganz am ende
wird alles mit pulver mit lebensmittel
pulver verfeinert und dann sieht es
glaube ich schon gut aus also hier
halbieren da halbieren
und dann diese finger
mit euren fingern schön lang formen ja
und die füße sind eigentlich genauso
dann nimmt eine loch hülle für die
kralle
und wenn es dann mit pulver später
verfeinert wird dann sieht man ihren
organs gut und dann könnt ihr zum
beispiel einen pinsel nehmen oder einen
anderen runden gegenstand legt die
finger dann darüber
damit sie auch schön die form annehmen
und so aus herten können
[Musik]
ab strengen
höfler den perfekten schnitt zu
verpassen
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die torte mit garage
einstreichen also erstmal hier auslösen
dies ist schön fest
[Musik]
ich möchte dass der koffer auch schön
alt und gebraucht aussieht also nicht
komplett gerade und glatt einstreichen
sondern so ein bisschen weil ich damit
einfach das leder später auch schön
aussieht und jetzt werde ich erstmal
eine erste schicht machen damit sie die
ganzen kuchen krümmel und die
buttercreme eingepackt ist dann wird die
erste schicht fest und dann mache ich
die zweite schicht drauf und das ist
dann die finale schicht
[Musik]
der teig karte könnte immer den rand
schön sauber machen
und nachdem die erste schicht getan ist
kommt die torte in den kühlschrank damit
die ganache festwirt und dann kann man
die zweite schicht nämlich schön einfach
auftragen
jetzt mache ich den koffer verschluss
dafür nehme ich auch mit dem master oder
ihr nehmt einfach blüten passte die hat
nämlich sofort raus und ich mache jetzt
einfach eine kleine schablone wegen der
größe und werde die blüten passe ganz
dünn ausrollen und entsprechend meiner
schablonen zu schneiden zum einen
brauche ich den part wo praktisch das
schloss drauf ist und zum anderen
brauche ich den unteren part mit dem
schlüsselloch drauf und das alles
zweimal
[Musik]
kommt die schnelle dran
und wenn ihr dann ein cm streifen
braucht könnt ihr euch einfach die
silikon matte zu hilfe nehmen und
einfach ich hier immer so eine type
karte ansetzen dann habt ihr schon einen
gleichmäßigen streifen und hier könnte
auch immer die maße einfach nehmen zu
hilfe die ecken so ein bisschen abrunden
dann am besten über einen stift legen
dann habt ihr nämlich diese aussparung
und gerne mit damit sommerloch schule
dran nähten
und dann braucht ihr noch mal ein dünnes
teil für den metallring für den leder
griff
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sobald die elemente aus blüten pasta
getrocknet sind könnte sie jetzt
metallisch einfärben ich nehme dafür
hier das metallic screen gold und kann
es damit schön einsprühen was ihr
alternativ auch leben können ist
metallic farbe zum auf pinseln oder auch
metallic prüfe farbe dann können wir es
einfach wie im trockenen pinsel
auftragen die teile lasse jetzt trocknen
und später werden sie noch mit etwas
pulver farbe auf alt getrimmt dass es
nicht ganz so neu aussieht weil jetzt
finde ich sie zahlt richtig schön
glänzend neu aus aber es ist ein alter
koffer deswegen lass ich trocknen und
wird später noch etwas einfallen lassen
ok schicht nummer zwei du wirst die
schöne schicht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich habe echt ein problem damit
künstlicher wellen in meiner torte zu
machen ich war eigentlich immer gerne
gerade mache und glatt es ist ein alter
koffer ich muss es tun
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also für so harten übergängen gibt es
kein besseres werkzeug als die finger
durch die leichte wärme trägt nämlich
die gerne schön verstrichen
alle ecken und kanten weg
und dann habt ihr eine schöne koffer
form
so kommt die torte jetzt noch mal im
kühlschrank zuerst werde ich hier so
ohne verpackung ein bisschen lagern bis
die oberfläche leicht an trocknet und
dann wirklich schön luftdicht
verschließen und dann bis morgen ins
kühlfach geben wenn ihr auch solche
lebensmittel pulver farben habt dann
könnt ihr jetzt damit wirklich ganz ganz
tolle schattierungen machen und dann
sehen eure torten eure figur und einfach
noch lebendiger aus ich habe jetzt hier
schwarz braun rot und orange und damit
werde ich das jetzt einfach alles aus
stadt ihren schön trocken also das heißt
keine flüssigkeit mit verwenden schön
trockene kinder benutzen und dann geht's
los und was ich da noch hat ist ein
bisschen metallic farbe fürs auge und
für die kleinsten fingernägel dieses
nämlich glänzen
ok
[Musik]
mein nißler nicht wir machen die zwei
abends und machen dann morgen mit der
torte wieder weiter den lasse ich jetzt
hier einfach bei raumtemperatur stehen
passt auf dass keine kinder dran gehen
und dann kann er morgen auf die fertige
torte gesetzt werden aber jetzt brauchen
wir echt ein bisschen ruhe meine finger
tun weh man rücken tut weh ohne fleiß
sitzungen bestehen würde er darf jetzt
ein bisschen da hinten geschlafen
jetzt geht's ans dekorieren ich habe
hier fondant mit vollmilchschokolade
denn ich finde da passt die farbe
einfach perfekt zum koffer und vor allem
schmeckt davon dann richtig gut schmeckt
einfach wie modelle schokolade weil 25
prozent echte vollmilch schokolade
enthalten ist das heißt da kann man den
von ganz schön mit essen weil es einfach
ein schöner schoko überzug ist dem knete
jetzt weich und dann rolle ich ihnen auf
ich schätze mal auf drei millimeter aus
und ich werde es schon einiges brauchen
denn die torte ist groß
so viel von land unsere riesentorte ich
mache jetzt auch so dass auch die
unterseite auf jeden fall ne fondant
decke bekommt damit später beim
anschnitt den koffer halten deckel und
eben auch im boden hat das heißt ich
muss die torte gleich stürzen ab seit
darum mach erst mal den boden
ich habe die welt natürlich aus der hand
dieser schwer
drei
hoch geschafft
so wie wir so viele torten bagso große
braucht man halt kein fitnessstudio
merkel
von rom hat immer aus das war eigentlich
schon witzig später mal zu wissen wie
schwer es ist musste man meine waage
später wurde die personenwagen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt keine garage mehr übrig
aber möchte die unterseite auch noch ein
bisschen bestreichen da jetzt einfach
den uhk krems hat bitter von frima
einfach dass ich so einen kleber habt
zwischen torte und fondant und dass dort
wo noch ein leckerer kleber denn die
muss nur etwas ist echt richtig gut dann
richtig leckeren brotaufstrich dem man
auch mit verpacken kann meine schwester
ist echt gut
[Musik]
falls sie übrigens ab und zu den
backofen hört ich mag gerade nebenher
noch 400 bananen brot muffins für
die musik für das musical auftritt heute
abend für den kindern und deswegen haben
wir hier den backofen gerade in
dauerbetrieb ich freu mich schon den
ganzen tag angerührt habe und ja die
ganze zeit im backofen auf backofen so
ok die decke kommt jetzt da drauf
ich hoffe ich habe jetzt genug
den rand wegschneiden aber ich lasse ein
bisschen rand noch übrig
also ein bisschen überstehen
dann kann ich jetzt den rest wieder
zusammen kneten nochmal der decke
ausrollen und dann
werde ich jetzt nach und nach ich glaube
erst mal die seiten einkleiden und dann
den deckel
erst die seiten ja erst mal so ein
langes band
coach
weitergeht muss
schon sagen wenn man viele torten macht
viele motiv torten einreise für lhon
frisch da muss man den fendant nicht
erreicht hätten und
ich brauche was zu essen
mir geht nämlich die kraft aus die
unterseite meines körpers ist selbst
schon mit fondant überzogen jetzt rolle
ich ein paar längliche streifen aus und
zwar so lang und so breit dass sie
wirklich um die vier seiten des compass
passen und da könnt ihr es euch ein
bisschen einfacher machen und entweder
zwei lange streifen machen die dann
beide seiten abdecken oder einfach vier
kürzere streifen machen und wirklich
jede seite einzeln für sich abdecken bei
mir ist die torte ungefähr 38 x 30 cm
groß und etwa 9 cm hoch gut dann habe
ich jetzt hier diese vier streifen und
fast hätte ich das leder muster
vergessen ich habe da noch so eine folie
die hatte ich mir mal bestellt und zwar
ist einfach so eine imprägnierung seine
präge folie und die lege ich jetzt doch
drauf ich gucke jetzt mal welche seite
habe ich glaube es macht keinen
unterschied doch so rum
und musste jetzt beim ausrollen starb da
rein machen
ich hoffe dass platz sorgen
[Musik]
wer nämlich jetzt einfach das booklet
und
das könnt ihr nämlich auf die richtige
breite einstellen
[Musik]
ich sagte ich weiß nicht wie ich das
tragen soll
[Musik]
jetzt modell ihre ich noch den koffer
griff dafür nämlich modelle vom band
rollt den schön aus schneidet dann einen
breiten streifen zu und präge da eine
prägende ein mit so einem modell
werkzeug zum ausfüllen des christlich
jetzt noch die süßigkeiten rein ihr
könnt den griff aber auch komplett aus
fondant formen
jetzt einfach noch zu kleben und die
goldenen halter anbringen und gut
trocknen lassen
[Musik]
ok dann kann der trocknen und ich mache
den großen deckel
klingt ja immer wieso so bis hin zu
einer versuchs werkstatt sind albert
einstein beim backen
[Musik]
hätte da werde ich von mal zu mal
schwächer oder die torte von mal zu mal
hier hatte ich ein bisschen zu wenig und
habe da jetzt einfach nur mittel creme
draufgemacht gut jetzt torte ausmessen
ausschneiden drauflegen und hier mache
ich jetzt allerdings so ja ja ja ich
mache es auf beiden seiten zwei
zentimeter länger
damit ich noch diesen rand vom käufer
hat also
vier zentimeter größer und dann schneide
ich da so zack zack zack zack zack
zu machen
immer mit einem stumpfen messer auf der
back matte auf der matte geht auch ein
spitzes messer 41 37 4
[Musik]
und hier
ich hoffe es klappt halt immer alles so
wie ich mir das so in meinem kopf raus
man muss nämlich hier jeweils eine
2 cm dicke weg
bevor ich das fest rückt klebe ich aber
noch hier an den rand den übergang
[Musik]
die ecken übergebe ich jetzt alle mit
einem langen stück damit der übergang
kaschiert wird
[Musik]
und der kreis bildet dann den ecken
schutz und ist eben ein hübsches detail
[Musik]
unten reichen dann auch halbkreise
es ist vollbracht meine koffer form ist
fertig ich habe alle nieten dran alle
lederbänder deckel seitenteile der
koffer sieht alt aus aber ist noch nicht
fertig denn gleich kommen noch die leder
beschichtung aber ich brauche eine kurze
pause muss meine küche einmal freiräume
und sorge machen und dann werden wir
gleich den koffer
okay mein koffer
wird jetzt lackiert es nimmt dafür
bakterien spray ihr könnt aber auch
einen alkohol nehmen wodka zum beispiel
oder in weißem rum und dann pulver
farben damit anrühren und damit er den
koffer schön glänzend bekommt und dass
er eben auch ein bisschen farbe bekommt
also an den tieferen stellen kommen dann
ein bisschen schwarz rhein
und der rest wird halt ein schönes leder
braun ich glaube ich mache es
tatsächlich so ich besprüht
[Musik]
hier mache noch so ein bisschen schatten
und auf alt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
da ist jetzt fertig und ich finde es
richtig schön geworden ich habe jetzt
doch keine uhr zwischen die hände
gemacht sondern mich liebt der gold
deswegen hat er jetzt hier ein paar
goldammer und niklas gold ist ein
extrakt erhält einfach meine kunden
exakt
susanne flop und du kommst jetzt auf den
griff
so gefällt mir richtig gut ich glaub dem
löffler auch
du brauchst kein gold masuren kaum
probiert den koffer kuchen
pizza klappt
perfekt
ich habe jetzt hier noch ein tolles
gewinnspiel für euch der film
fantastische tier wesen damen blut aus
geheimnisse läuft ja schon seit dem 17
april in allen deutschen kinos und ihr
könnt jetzt hier eins von fünf gewinn
paketen gewinnen und zwar darin
enthalten ein schnüffler zwei
kinotickets für den film und dann
bekommt ihr noch was von mir dazu
nämlich ein will extrakt meines elliott
schießt ein pinsel set zu modellieren
und dekorieren eurer torten eine back
matte einen aus holz starb mit den
ganzen ringen dran und noch ein mini
spritztouren set damit ihr schöne torten
dekorieren und backen könnt und alles
was ihr dafür tun müsst schreibt einfach
gerne in die kommentare wie euch meine
torte gefällt und dann seid ihr
automatisch beim gewinnspiel schon mit
dabei blick weiss
ich finde zauberspruch gesagt habe
vorhin hast du das gesehen wieder nicht
viel drauf geflogen ist ich habe
geschrieben wer ist der wahl da hinten
drauf
auf der torwart uns da hierher geflogen
durch magie
ich hab gesagt ne flatow brauchst kein
gold mehr suchen probiert auch diesen
koffer kochen
herr ganz logisch ja wir schneiden an
und dann zaubern wir noch ein paar
menschen her die dann die torte
probieren okay
du hast mich kurz überlegen ja
ok
ok kommen schneiden wir schneiden an
oder sommer erst die leute her rufen ja
wir rufen da ist er auch gemacht ein
zauberspruch aber du musst sagen
also er ist sauber spruch geht so
abrakadabra
manchester weiter 170
karamell schoko und banane ich brauche
eine köstliche kuchen abnahme
[Gelächter]
nein es war von die wichtige
generalprobe es war schon hier eine
liste mit koffer ja und da kommen wir
schneiden sie zusammen und die haben
strich die natur
[Musik]
das war
uns zusammen hochheben ich bin nur
gespannt
warte ich schneide uns mal eine scheibe
ab okay sie dann nicht auch sie so eine
ledertasche und
jetzt probiert doch mal
probiert natürlich die von dann schicht
ganz durchschneiden man muss noch dazu
sagen die von dann schicht schmeckt auch
gut weil die schokoladen fondant drauf
ist
ich bin gespannt wird es immer schmeckt
wie bans mit
[Musik]
recht wie banana split
muss sagen ich bin ich eine coole
hochzeitstorte für
richtige magie fans denn mal da ich
glaub da wollen viele nicht so eine
normale herkömmliche torte dann so ein
reisekoffer flitterwochen koffer mit
seinem löffler darauf
dass mit dem
marzipan außen und innen reis christie's
mit
die füße
dass qualm hat sich seine fingernägel
lackiert wie in seinem
friseursalon
pediküre maniküre gemacht ja
rolle
also was ist ihr fazit leckere torte
sehr lecker
richtig gut ich muss aber dazu sagen
dass die jetzt echt so ein paar tage
durchgezogen ist wo die schmeckt echt
gut und die fondant schicht dieser
wirklich schön drum rum und schützt die
torte das innere und es ist einfach
alles schön saftig kann gut durchziehen
der putzige händler vom dortmann schnitt
aber das macht nichts so alles
lebensmittelfarbe erfurter fleißig
weiter und ihr könnt euch gerne auch den
film freuen kann das steht ihr wesen
damit auf geheimnisse ab dem 17 april im
kino das heißt der läuft jetzt schon ein
paar tage und ich denke es ist ein
wahnsinnig toller film die filme
allgemein sind ja immer wahnsinnig
aufwendig auch gemacht und auch diese
magie welt muss ich sagen einfach
einzigartig also schaut euch den film
gerne an macht gerne auch beim
gewinnspiel mit ihr könnt dann wie
gesagt 15 paketen gewinnen ich freue
mich auf eure kommentare und wir sehen
uns wieder beim nächsten mal und gerne
dürfte mir auch schreiben welche torte
ihr euch als nächstes wünscht
ja weil die torte wilde zeit gegessen
und dann haben wir morgen bestimmt
wieder stoff für neue traute
[Gelächter]
ich trau mich nicht denn deflation essen
okay wir zaubern und zweck
sauber ja sagt ein zauberspruch
die grimaud
[Gelächter]
so gut
war so lecker dass sie sich besser aus
als ein echter koffern
[Musik]